her in the court order in the court the
premiere of a locally filmed movie is
also a fundraiser for the animal
foundation really a good idea for a fun
family outing later today the movie
called popovich road to hollywood
stars gregory popovich as an
accident-prone wannabe star i'm on the
way to
college
who gets in trouble with more than just
the law do you know who i am
in a small town that looks a lot like
boulder city now popovich's name might
sound familiar his comedy pet theater
show has been on the las vegas strip for
years in the movie popovich ends up in
front of a judge after managing to
topple a statue and if that broken
statue is not fixed in those two weeks
he fails at a warehouse job
gets a job at a restaurant
where a waitress befriends him while the
town dog catcher keeps trying to track
him down the movie's got everything
including the kitchen sink surrounded by
adorable cats and dogs
kitchen sink so the movie is downtown in
las vegas the art house theater starts
at six they're having three different
screenings 15 minutes apart to maximize
social distancing technically admission
is free but they're hoping that you will
make a donation to support the ongoing
work of the animal foundation looks like
a very serious film yeah obviously very
dramatic oh yeah it's war and peace
but it's so much fun gregory papua has
been around town for a long time so fun
to work with them and the
young men who were on the team making
the movie have been making commercials
and these little 48-hour films for quite
some time and glad to just be one small
part of it yeah goodness see and again
that movie theater downtown we were
talking about before really it's a great
theater so if you can get there it's
downtown a lot of good fun